hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three say oh s---
still don't know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly cuz i varied all over the
place now this one is actually
interesting to me because I don't know
why she died it would explain it if she
was with mr. Sato it has to be Yoshi no
and her lackeys who put me sales text on
the board they're the lowest to the low
but Emma's kind of gross I feel bad for
Toma having to read that putrid poem
it's mu should be sorry for I thought
that poem was cute oh it's a tome a
that's right what about the other girl
oh maybe she's not that was her name
like like Samantha's friend told me
you're just too nice God sorry about the
mouse I forgot about the mouse oh did he
hear us well she hears you now she's
right next to you dot dot dot
ah I forgot my hand kerchief M did you
forget your handkerchief huh huh I'll
lend you mine it's a Tomei just give it
back whenever liar
trying to act like a goody two-shoes you
were the one who put up my text for all
the see weren't you what an awful girl
she must have tricked Thoma did she lo
did she really are you sure about that
one maybe maybe not gross why do I keep
looking in toilet so what's with o gotta
box huh o is a good item to have when
I'm in a nightmare world where do I keep
getting bats
I really should probably check my sanity
why break down the door absolutely okay
alright then open wide Toma ah ah tasty
hmm
you make the best lunches of Tomei you'd
make a great wife mine obviously
Oh Toma as a bitterly
relationship to be making such a
proclamation like that I won't give you
Thomas to me Tim is all mine
Toma damn boy my Toma
otama let's go now da da da da da Toma
em Em's the only one for me drummer
samba you're kidding right
you told me this M thing was just a game
my dad had told me I lied I love em
whatever name is I'm so glad so much
that can't be right Toma you okay - you
don't like me hey you're the one is just
a friend and you're the one for me and
you're my Toma I love you and I love you
like a chocolate waterfall no stop no
get your hands off Toma citta may oh I'm
back here okay
what am i doing I gonna bash toe his
head in all right
they're passionately kissing they won't
notice a bad to the back of the head
that's for sure hello
so tell me stay with me go over your
eyes - ma you need to get a grip suit oh
man
what do you see him Toma he's all
appearance you're wrong
that was cool and kind and he always
protects me about that
think back to when you were attacked in
the bathroom domina
deserted you Tama wouldn't desert me
Toma he pass away tell me don't help AG
why it's Omer ah Toma left me to die
yeah
Samantha can I have that bad o.o
appropriate choices in moral correctness
ah good I don't need you Toma I hate you
I know MA oh ah totally healthy Oh
so healthy that baby's gonna grow up
strong okay a path opened up there but
also there's the path over to the right
I want to go snap hello what's this
something on the ground
sokka's hairpin oh oh oh yeah this is
what happened
oh oh so mister soda did she uh yeah Kia
that really doesn't matter right now so
let's get somewhere safe no way I can
see everything yeah blah blah blah fine
what do I care
oh boy oh there's Samantha a stationary
no mistake it's Samantha's who what do I
care she says and now comes the love
letter well let's see what kind of
juiciness is in this sucker this is a
cursed letter if you don't send this to
five other people in a week you will be
cursed key alright time to check out the
Lord roar what do we have here
Lou Oh God
oh yeah what are these arms
mr. sodas
okay don't judge that oh boy good still
not rotten your body is truly miraculous
to stay fresh over three months
Oh God
Oh mmm oh this guy's nuts oh oh no no
you can't escape oh my goodness gravy
golly gosh that guy is oh my love I got
you no running away now
about earlier don't tell anyone will you
it's a secret between us no no I see
that's unfortunate
then I'll have to kill you eek oh boy uh
uh Yaka mr. soda oh ah help that's yeah
okay uh okay calm down the monsters are
gone a yoga teacher would happen to
Ayaka she was in a panic after be oh god
this oh don't be fooled he was trying to
kill me oh good
oh-oh-oh
now then no one to get in the way no oh
I can't run like this oh my god oh why
does he have to be so crazy he looked
crazy I see the crazy look in his eyes
now idiot girl you were the one who
fought me flawless uh-huh Oh God
mr. soda Kelly akka I'm so sorry I
didn't notice a Yaka oh but that's
strange why didn't me cells body rot
that is also the power of a curse
even in pieces she desperately tried to
live you're very keen on sticking around
yeah it makes sense okay so does grave
why not
I don't think this guy deserves
redeeming so okay where is this alright
that's an empty house okay the screen is
lit up inspected okay I was satisfied at
first hmm I enjoyed being loved by all
but suddenly it was all Hollow it wasn't
me who everyone loved it was my mass mr.
soda is crazy mask
great good good good good
is that Ayaka Hi'iaka she doesn't notice
oh hello mr. soda
mr. soda is totally the best a little
mysterious but that only makes him even
better
lucky Ayaka having him for homeroom I am
so jealous
ah mr. soda it's just so beautiful he's
got a great face way better than any of
those boys
yes run away and his personality is
killer too totally kind and reliable
that's teachers biggest charm he's not
all appearance hearts okay now right
okay yet crazy I wonder if I can get mr.
sodas number she doesn't seem to see
Samantha Rhett okay alright okay
so I need to follow mr. soda to find the
bottom of this damn it everyone always
goes on about my parents damn it being
this handsome it's so hard was it ionic
girls this this is in my face what is
okay bye alright then oh hello mr. soda
having a super game I guess hello okay
bye the new book
oh hi Hideki SOTA looking tired
could this be mr. soda okay what are you
doing here stir yeah Oh mr. SIL yeah
good stir God declares don't be fools
think she dropped your eggs if should I
give it to her huh what what is it
you dropped your handkerchief no way you
so that's it don't yeah my name is your
filthy hand yours
no I'll give it back I don't worry peg
now you bros okay so do you jerk you
make it boil girls cry you're the worst
don't even bring your grubby mitts to
school okay
that's weird
know it except me rice okay was that
teachers pass yeah of course it was
yeah ding-dong what do we have here
seems you could fit in so oh hi
no one accepts me oh you can't run
anymore what the baloney
what well that's not fair what okay
what maybe I need a item from the other
room before that actually happens so
that I can I don't know do some
something in here that I can get before
I go well what the boob why do I haven't
item we don't have an item with what
what sir Oh what what the okay I I don't
know what's going on right now
how much ah my just dead my just dead is
this this game over or something oh I
can move oh I didn't know I can move oh
I thought I was suck okay I'm okay all
right here we go - okay all right
literally - I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait a little bit on this one there oh
hi what
okay waiting with the bad choice what oh
yeah
oh yes I'll come out of the closet then
I can I guess what do I do
okay here we go that was a good choice
I'm glad I did that dead
that cat looked dead I was I didn't
think it was okay man mr. soda has a
complicated past
hi everyone exactly I hate now okay it
was a meow
you tell fragile I need to get you a hot
dog
hey I'm gonna help you
I'm sorry oh she's beyond saving no well
I was that one opportunity I can t use
that voice it was a good voice to this
job
Fuli eyes out you do baby could you get
a lot more of this voice instead teacher
I don't feel sorry for him cats grave
the poor veterinarian
well I'll such a dignified voice gone
forever Mia Oh hard fade away no there
is baby oooh I thought between different
teams you you really gonna eat that
thing loser his dump is a perfect place
for Thota ha ha ha you say hey say today
hmm
your names go just sick burn breath you
really got him oh are you ok Jackie no
she she was in mr. sodas class do you
mind if I I sit with you huh it's ok if
you don't want me sorry no no no that I
can so can i yeah
do i do what do I stay chuckles si AV
why don't talk to me I talk you know
heads are so pretty hey you always eat
lunch here uh yeah see it's nice here
it's quiet and calming yeah I got
through yeah yeah sorry what is it
I couldn't do anything when you were
being teased dog
can I come again tomorrow uh let's see
lunch together huh you if you eat with
me you'll just be teased
oh you lose easily relieved duty I don't
mind i i won't back down i was feigning
ignorance out of fear I was turned from
reality but I'm gonna stop from now on
I'll protect you soda huh I'm am i
bothering you no never do not bid
goodbye but it's early you can't have
you got teased because me I I mean I
feel guilty and having a girl stand up
for me
ha BT more I guess so I'm sorry uh but
but I really appreciate the thought
we'll start forming ended up didn't know
Syl it won't change the I want to
protect you soda come to me anytime
you're in trouble I'll be with anything
to attacking you this is a thank you hey
I want you to know better soda I wanna
know you better soda
this might be a long episode I wouldn't
want to get through this in this one she
was the first refers to Debbie I was so
happy and then I decided to turn the
murder I guess so this goes all wrong
somehow eventually we met there I'm
attorneys he's gonna become the veteran
we met there every day afterward we
didn't talk to each other we just spent
time together conversation wasn't
necessary my heart wasn't ease with her
there
we were happy cuz the dumb voice gets
annoying after a while
everyone's gonna have this voice from
now on ah
that cloud looks like a sheep it's true
it's cute yeah yeah taco no smiling
she's cute too
like that sheep up there I love two
hands and a voice and a smile I fell for
her my first love I love taco no yes I
do I really do I love her love love love
to taka no hmm huh SOTA what's the
matter
let let go darker no I love you huh what
um so I love you I love you taco
ah tadaka
you creep
huh why I'm sorry what why I thought you
accepted me why why why I'm look I'm
really sorry
I didn't mean to get close to you for
that kind of thing I just felt bad for
you soda sorry it's nothing we should
stop meeting here okay huh
what no no why why won't anyone except
me
Oh oh come on man why why won't anyone
except me
soda stop why why somebody help
Oh soda what are you doing ah no it
accepts me no one
that's quite a breakage of the camel's
back from a straw if you know what I
mean
you think I'm disgusting too don't you I
do now not for your looks
that's for damn sure okay unfortunately
I am gonna end this one here and I'm
gonna finish up in one more episode
sorry
just going to have to do it that way I
apologize sincerely so thank you all so
much for watching I will see you
don't you put your shoulder s that's not
very good school you need to really
learn okay ladies let's get one thing
straight
just wool it's ugly that dress oh okay
yeah my feeling klappa where you come
from what the hell